[Musik]
was genau hier abgeht und das ist ein
ich habe zuvor in drei jahre lang war
selber vor zwei jahren beim casting in
einer selben konzerne hier und habe mich
dann halt informiert und das hat mir
echt gut gefallen und jetzt bin ich
schon fast ein jahr dabei die ganzen
mädels die hierher kommen können sich
wirklich um jede waffengattung
informieren
und ich finde es extrem toll weil zu
kriegen sie im kleinen einblick waffen
soldaten leben macht
[Musik]
ein eingespieltes team auf sondern gibt
auch keine berührungsängste
[Musik]
[Applaus]
einfach
[Musik]
damit tritt der bisherige wies
entstellung gelegt aber es gibt viele
und anziehen
[Musik]
die kernrate zusammenarbeiten
das zusammen immerhin fahren jetzt
miteinander das ist aber auch kein
trauma timo was
[Applaus]